I can this episode is brought to you by
read wise read wise is one of the cooler
things I've found in the last year or
two sent to me by one of my best friends
it is an app that helps you remember
significantly more of what you read in
fact on average their users report
remembering 84 percent more of what
they've read and highlighted and it can
take a few different forms you can sign
up for the service that's read wise dot
io forward slash Tim and get a daily
email which I do so I've got in front of
me one example with highlights from
fooled by randomness sapiens priceless
and a bunch of other books and it has a
bunch of advanced features on top of
that but we've all had the experience of
reading a book or article looking back a
couple of weeks later to realize that
you don't remember anything from it or
next to nothing
read wise solves this problem by
integrating with Kindle Pocket iBooks
instapaper and more to send you a daily
digest of all your highlights so it
helps you to build a fun daily habit
I love getting these emails which I
can't believe I'm even syncs I hate
email but I love getting these so you
get a daily email in simplest form and
you can review and actually use the
hundreds of perhaps even thousands of
highlights that are just sitting in your
reading devices collecting cyberdust
and this simple habit of reviewing your
highlights daily can dramatically
improve how much information you retain
through spaced repetition and actually
use and quite frankly it's just fun it's
really fun to see what you've
highlighted over the years and forgotten
about so it's really good I mean these
are things that ostensibly you wanted to
remember read wise also provides tools
for organizing your books articles and
highlights so tagging searching adding
notes creating flashcards all that kind
of stuff you can even tell read wise to
automatically export your highlights to
Evernote this is a big deal for me I've
had to do this manually in the past but
read wise makes it painless and super
super simple and it just takes seconds
to sign up I was astonished by this I
thought the import
the Kindle would take a really long time
it takes no time at all and believe it
or not you can also use read wise with
paper books that is if you have a
paperback or something you can
automatically get the top popular
highlights for your books simply by
adding their titles and you can also
create your own highlights with the apps
camera highlighting feature this stuff
is super cool so there's no reason not
to try this out I think it's incredibly
incredibly useful incredibly cool and
very fun go to read wise dot io forward
slash Tim that's read wise dot io
forward slash Tim for two month free
trial offered exclusively to Tim Ferriss
show listeners again that's read wise
dot IO forward slash Tim for two month
free trial read wise do forward slash
Tim check it out this episode is brought
to you by you can that's UCAN I was
introduced to you can and it's unique
carbohydrates super starch by my good
friend and listen her favorite doctor
Peter Atia a lot of you know who that is
and he said there is really no carb in
the world to quite like it and just as
context peter has spent two to three
years at a time
in ketosis that is effectively with a
diet absent of carbohydrates but Peter
has written about how he stayed in
ketosis while using you can regularly
and how there is almost no insulin
response is very odd it's very unusual
and there's a cool story behind it which
I'll tell you about as Peter has written
it does not behave like a carbohydrate
with respect to insulin secretion and
ketone suppression so I have since
included it in my routine using you cans
powders to power my workouts and the
bars also as great snacks specifically
the chocolate anytime energy bar at just
one hundred and eighty calories has been
a lifesaver it helps me to stay sharp
even if I start to fade at the end of
the day and I suppose that isn't
surprising when you consider that super
starch has been shown in studies to
improve accuracy at the end of a soccer
game and improve cognition when you are
exhausted the company backstory is
really interesting it was founded with a
mission to help children with a rare
metabolic disorder that prevents the
body from producing glucose on its own
you cans discovery of a patented
carbohydrate that
as mentioned is called super starch now
helped those children sustain glucose
levels to keep them alive now in the
world of performance you can is
regularly purchased by more than 400 pro
and college teams that have won every
imaginable championship keeping their
athletes energy steady in the weight
room on the field and elsewhere
extensive scientific research and
clinical trials have shown that
super-stretch provides a sustained
release of energy to the body without
spiking blood sugar you can is the ideal
way to source energy from carbohydrate
without the negatives associated with
fast carbs especially sugar so you can
avoid fatigue hunger cravings loss of
focus all of that with this technology
whether an athlete working on your
fitness or you need efficient calories
to get you through your day you can is
an elegant energy solution so check it
out this stuff is very very cool and you
guys my listeners can save 25% on your
first you can order by going to you can
dot Co that's UCAN dot co and using
promo code Tim that's you can co and
promo code Tim you also get free
shipping if you are in the u.s. so check
it out go to you Ken dot CO and use
promo Tim for 25% off and free shipping
that is us only on your first order and
that when in doubt just try the
chocolate anytime energy bar it is
simply fantastic you can Co promo code
Tim hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types my guest today is someone I have
wanted to have a long conversation with
for decades in fact Michael Lewis
Michael Lewis is the best-selling author
of many books and several of my favorite
books including liars poker Moneyball
The Blind Side the big short the undoing
project and the fifth risk both of his
books about sports became movies
excellent movies nominated for Academy
Awards as did the Big Short his book
about the 2008 financial crisis he lives
in Berkeley California with his wife and
three children his critically acclaimed
podcast against the rules
returns with season two on Tuesday May
5th 2020 last season Michael explored
the attack on referees of all different
types and sports financial markets
newsrooms courts of law and the art
world this time around
Michael focuses on coaches why the role
of coach has expanded beyond sports in
American life and why everyone seems to
love coaches each episode examines a
different kind of coach I loved episode
3 on the inner coach but I'm cheating
and got a sneak peak from money coaches
and voice coaches to college coaches and
even the one who changed his own life
Michael delves deep inside the vast
world of the coach I really enjoyed
these episodes and I highly recommend
that you check out against the rules and
he tackles questions such as can a good
coach level the playing field what is
the secret to effective coaching what
role do coaches have in creating
unfairness
can everyone be coached or are some
people beyond help check it out against
the rules new season right now I
recommend and to this conversation I had
a blast it's so much fun in this
conversation we cover a lot of ground
creative process formative experiences
his mentors and coaches we go all over
the place so without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with none other than Michael Lewis
Michael welcome to the show pleasure to
be here and I have a secret to confess
not much of a secret but it's some
backstory that makes me smile and that
is when I was just out of college this
is mm I had moved to the Bay Area for my
first job this entry-level stuck in the
middle of a fire exit desk job and I had
volunteered at an organization called
the Silicon Valley Association of
startup entrepreneurs s-phase I don't
know if it even exists anymore and I
finally got myself the ability to
recruit speakers for an event and I
reached out to you this was in 2000
through the Princeton alumni network and
you very very kindly declined but it was
so well delivered it was so diplomatic
that it always stuck with me and I've
wanted to have a conversation for 20
years now and so I thought I would just
share that and thank you for being so
kind to someone who really had very
little to offer well well you know you
were you you were in the majority I tend
to kind of hide and and the and to the
extent I can hide I do hide but the the
I think it probably would time I've
become a little bit more abrupt in
explaining to people that I just don't
want to do it so I'm glad you caught me
at a sweet-natured moment of my career
well I thought we could start very early
in your career although this may predate
your writing career by a little bit and
to discuss one of your lesser-known
pieces of writing and this is a let's
call it a book review of Johnny Tremain
am i pronouncing that correctly good yes
please can you please tell this story so
this is very funny you bring this up
because just two days ago I called my
mother and asked her if I could
interview her for my podcast and she
said no she's not no interest in it and
I said I just want to ask you about what
you remember about all the trouble
got into when I was kind of 6th grade
through 10th grade and she said I don't
remember anything and I said oh come on
you remember me almost getting thrown
out of school and she says oh is that
the time when you copied the back of the
book and handed it in as your own work
and she remembered that and so what had
happened was we were I was I must have
been in the seventh grade possibly eight
and we were given the assignment of
writing a book review of Johnny Tremain
and I remember taking it home and
looking at the back of the book and
thinking there's an excellent review
just here on the back of the book
summarizes it exactly as it is save me
the trouble of reading it and so I just
copied it out and I handed it in and I
swear to you I know it's going to be
very hard for you to believe this but I
swear to you I had no sense I was doing
anything wrong I thought I was doing
something that was kind of efficient
that the teacher would be very happy to
have such a cleanly written thing that
it saved me all kinds of trouble so I
had go out in the front yard and play
basketball in baseball and and that
nobody would mind and it comes back to
me with a an a every American still
remembers it in red and then in red ink
see me and I went to see the teacher and
the teacher said where'd you get this
and I said I got it off the back of the
book and he said that's plagiarism and I
said what's and I swear to you this is
true I said what's plagiarism
I had no native sense that this was some
sort of theft and he was so outraged he
went to the principal and the principal
the middle school principal was so
outraged he actually threw me out of the
Isidore Newman school K through 12
school that my parents had gone to my
grandparents had gone to I mean it was
really shocking and the only with the
intervention of the headmaster was I
allowed to stay in school and my
punishment this is actually gets even
better my punishment was to go home and
write 300 times I will not plagiarize
copying something that the teacher had
given me so so so that you know that
that was the I suppose the punch line to
it all is that piece of writing was the
first thing I ever handed in there ever
got any any particular attention
I got through the eighth grade without
anybody noticing that I could write one
thing or another and it wasn't till I
copied the back of a book and handed it
in as my own that anybody really noticed
that I could write well well let's talk
let's talk a little bit more about
noticing your writing evaluating your
writing if we flash forward to Princeton
undergrad and your interactions may be
at the tail end of that period of time
with your thesis advisors so the process
of doing homework for this conversation
I found and I don't know if this is an
exact transcription you can't always
rely on the internet but that you asked
him what do you think of the writing and
the thesis this is for your senior
thesis yes and he said never try to make
a living at it so good yeah is that true
and if so can you perhaps flesh that out
a little bit for us it's entirely true
he so as you know as a Princetonian the
senior thesis is a really big deal huge
and mostly not appreciated by anybody
else who went to any other kind of
college because they think of it oh it's
a paper it's not a paper it's a book and
you've got to essentially write a book
it's a short book but it's a forty or
fifty thousand word book and it and to
this day I have a recurring nightmare
that I that it's May or April and I
forgot I was supposed to write a senior
thesis I was but I was that up to that
point in my life I had no particular
sense of myself as a writer I did not
write for any school newspapers at any
point in my career I did not study
literature I did not I wasn't in the
English department of the creative
writing program nothing like that but
when I started working on this thesis I
became fully absorbed I mean just just
passionate about it and I really cared
what I was saying and how I said it
what was my subject matter started and
the subject matter it was in the art
history department Princeton the subject
matter was the way the Italian sculptor
Donatello
had used classical sources which sounds
arcane but it's actually getting at the
question of what the Renaissance the
Italian Renaissance thought it was doing
because it was very early creatively in
the Renaissance where they were starting
to actually refer back to Greek and and
and precedent a lot of things had been
dug up and and and the artists were
noticing it and the question was were
they when they just admiring it
technically or was there some with a
self-consciously
recreating antiquity and Donatello was a
really interesting way to do it and
there were interesting resources new
resources available to study the
question so there was a professor at
Columbia who had just compiled it was
just on microfiche in Manhattan called
something called the census of antique
work known to Renaissance artists so you
could sort of recreate what Donatello
had seen and then you could see how he
had used it in his various works so
anyway for me it was I was absorbed it
was actually from the point of view even
of the artists the art historians at
Princeton a pretty original project and
I handed it in and then I went to defend
it and I remember going through the
defense and the waiting for the
professor his name was William child's
William AP childs the fourth he was in
he was a classicist and he was a
fabulous professor I loved him and he
said but I kept waiting here him to say
Michael this thing is just beautifully
written anyway he wouldn't say it and so
finally I said it was the biggest
mistake I said what did you think of the
writing and he said put it this way
never try to make a living at it and and
I was undeterred by that I don't know
why but he didn't make me feel like oh I
should I really shouldn't be doing that
but it was the first it was the four it
was the first moment where I thought I
would I now know what I like to do for a
living if I could and I misconstrued it
a bit I thought what I wanted to be was
an art historian and I wrote books about
art history he persuaded me that there
would be no jobs in art history and I
should go find something else to do with
my life and so that left me with well
I'll write books how do you do that but
that's just as I'm walking out the door
of Princeton without any particular
preparation for them for the career when
did you graduate 1980 to 1982 all right
so we're gonna talk about 1989 in a
little bit but I wanted to ask you about
your formation as
writer or a thinker who puts pros down
on paper at least and how you developed
the ability to write without studying it
directly I've read that your father was
an expert storyteller or at least
inveterate storyteller I don't know if
that had any impact so I don't to lead
with the question but how did how did
you come to be able to express yourself
clearly in writing so this is
reconstructing it after the fact and God
knows how true it is but I'll give you
my best shot at it I think the
ingredients I think are I did grow up
with a father who he wasn't just that he
wasn't a yarn spinner but a wonderful
storyteller and and a very sophisticated
storyteller and very very very smart so
he didn't tell dumb stories he told
smart stories so I I grew up listening
to any is funny like really funny so I
grew up just and we were very close just
listening to really good stories and he
was also in his own way a superb writer
in that he he'd sort of internalized EB
White and Strunk and the omit needless
words part of that and be as pithy as
possible and he would edit my school
papers and I so I got to I began kind of
internalizing his criticism so I was get
to the point kind of thing which is a
very useful thing to internalize but
then you know then what happened when I
got out of Princeton it really it shows
you how accidental and haphazard careers
can be I had no idea of how to go about
being a writer I didn't know any writers
I didn't know anybody who knew any
writers there was no one in my family
who could kind of provide guidance it
was it was it was really as crude as I
walked into the bookstore like a like
some bookstore and said is there
anything in here that tells you how to
write for magazine for magazines and
there was at the time but a big fat
reference book which listed like the
eight thousand then magazines in America
along with the addresses and phone
numbers of the editors of
magazines and write out when I got out
of Princeton I started to submit full-on
pieces magazine pieces to willy-nilly to
journals and I would get responses all
the responses were no and I didn't know
what I was doing I had the sense that I
should go have lots of experiences in
life and then I would have things to
write about and so I was working in a
fancy art dealership in New York the
right when I got out but I was also I
was also the the head soup ladle er at
the Bowery mission and young men's home
for the homeless people when they came
through to eat their lunch and dinner
and so I got to know the homeless
population in New York for over a
stretch and I wrote a long piece about
them and about how you they weren't just
one thing they were all these different
characters and I but I said it I can
remember sending it off and I don't know
why I thought it was a good idea to the
in-flight magazines like Delta and
American and I remember the Delta late
whoever was editing the Delta in-flight
magazine wrote back and said you know
it's really interesting what you did but
you do realize we're trying to get
people to go to New York
not-not-not flee New York it just
doesn't it didn't fit and and so I kept
doing that though I kept sort of us
writing stuff and sending it in and the
the first hit I got please what got me
off the ground it was kind of two years
a year and a half and I got out of
Princeton I noticed in the back of the
Economist magazine a little
advertisement for the science and
technology pages and it said write a 600
word article and if your article it wins
the competition you'll get a job at the
Economist and it might have just been an
internship kind of job but it was a job
and so at that point I was living in
London and going to graduate school at
the London School of Economics and I'd
experienced the British medical system
and I realized that if I just went home
to New Orleans and went to our fanciest
Hospital and asked and whatever the
newest thing was the British would think
it was like 22nd century stuff they were
so that was so archaic in Britain so I
did that I found this breast cancer
detection device in the auktioner
Hospital in New Orleans
wrote 600 words about it sent it in and
got a call from a man whose name you
might recognize the name is Matt Ridley
now well-known a well-known author and
also a Lord Lord Matt Ridley but at the
time he was the deputy science editor of
The Economist and he says we'd like to
have you come in for an interview
and I came in for the interview and they
said you're on a short list of three
finalists for the job and and they
started to ask me what's your what's
your background in science and
technology this thing seemed seems like
you know you know a lot and I said well
I never actually took any science I had
to take a science class to get out of
Princeton and I took a class called
physics for poets and I took it
pass/fail Anna and I flunked it and I
flunked it because I played racquetball
instead of going to the lab but but any
case I had an F on my transcript at
Princeton and it was physics for poets
and I was telling this I thought they
would think this was a jolly tale and
they're like jaws on the floor and at
the end of this they say what are you
doing here and I said I want to write
and they say and they say but you you
don't know anything they said the other
two finalists for this are studying for
their doctorates in physics one at one
was a Cambridge when I was at Oxford
they say you don't remember Matt really
said it was great he said he said you're
a fraud at Europe but but you're a very
good fraud and that's a journalist and
he said you sir fooled us with his piece
and so he said we're not gonna give you
this job because you don't know anything
but we I would encourage you to keep
submitting things to the Economist and
so over the for over a period about a
year I must have published 20 articles
in the Economist in the different
sections and I go to them with ideas and
they were they were a delight and that's
how big they gave me my start that's how
it's the end and from there you know how
I go from there to writing a long-form
narrative nonfiction is a different
story but that's sort of the thing that
that gets me going what was it about
writing
or publishing what did that do for you
what did that feed or what feeling did
that evoke that kept you going through
all these rejections and in-flight
magazine letters well you know on this
is the truth is in the truth to this day
is that what I realized when I was
writing my Princeton thesis and
continued to fit since when I was
writing these magazine articles that
nobody wanted to publish is that the
thing itself gave me enormous pleasure
I mean subsequently I've had people my
children and my wife who have been in
the same room when I've like had
headphones on and trying to concentrate
and write something they said do you
realize that when you're sitting there
writing you're laughing the whole time
you like you're laughing at your own
jokes and in their view it's kind of
pathetic like you're sitting there
laughing in your own jokes and there's
this point to that but the bigger point
is I just took an enormous pleasure in
doing the thing and so it it never felt
like oh I shouldn't be doing this
because I was having so much fun doing
it and it was just like I just got to
get better I'll just keep I'll keep
doing this because I this is just fun so
the distinction between rejection and
acceptance and you know seeming failure
and success was was a very blurry
distinction to me because I was already
getting pleasure out of the doing of it
I was already excited by it now once
this I could remember when the first
thing hit print there was that Pete that
a little breast cancer detection piece
they did run it in the Science and
Technology basically a fat check you did
under different ways because they
wondered where the hell it came from but
but they but they ran it and I can't
just remember going might an economist
doesn't even run by wine so my name
wasn't even on it but I just went yeah I
mean this is I was just yeah this is
right and once my name started going on
things and it was things in the New
Republic or idly the op-ed page of The
Wall Street Journal started to invite me
to write for them all went out while I
was still a student I thought it was
just it was you know historic kerosene
on a on a bonfire it was already you
know it was already burning down the
neighborhood because I was are I was so
excited by what I was doing already I
didn't need it was sort of like I didn't
really need any encourage
as so getting the encouragement was just
gravy it is so if we if we flash forward
that I mean you're writing your
publishing I'm looking at a paragraph
from brain pickings dot org which is run
by Maria Popova who I'm very fond of and
there was a there's a piece on your
writing process she may have been
quoting a different source but I just
want to read something quickly and then
and then we can discuss before I wrote
my these are your words before I wrote
my first book 1989 the sum total of my
earnings as a writer over four years of
freelancing was about three thousand
bucks so it did appear to be financial
suicide when I quit my job at Salomon
Brothers where I had been working for a
couple of years and where I just gotten
a bonus of two hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars which they'd promised
they'd double the following year to take
a forty thousand dollar book advance for
a book that took a year and a half to
write was that a hard decision or was it
something you've just been biding your
time for and suddenly it was you put it
very well it was something I'd been
biding my time for that I when I went
into Salomon Brothers I knew that this
was a this was a this was a temp gig I'd
be there for a few years and and I was
there at more out of curiosity about how
this world work then I was to advance a
career in fact aside from the money
which I liked
I didn't think really much about the
career at Salomon Brothers because I
knew I could only hang out my interest
would only last for so long and I was
intensely interested in it as I was
learning about but when I kind of
figured it all out and got a sense of
how it all worked and there weren't any
more questions I had that needed to be
answered I really started to get bored
but the whole time I was there I was
writing and I I was I got myself in in
trouble because I'd actually tend to
write kind of about what's around me and
so I started to write things about this
great boom that was happening on Wall
Street was really the beginning of what
we still live with this notion of 22 or
23 year olds rolling on and being and
making a fortune the the
the sums of money being made on Wall
Street and the share of the economy it
occupied was expanding rapidly and no
one quite understood why so there was a
natural market for me to sort of try to
explain it and so I told I mentioned The
Wall Street Journal asked me to write
op-eds for them I wrote an op-ed arguing
that investment bankers were overpaid
and in the bottom of the op-ed it said
Michael Lewis is an associate on a
Salomon Brothers but you know I tell you
I must have like a blind streak right
because idea my reaction was WOW great
piece like when I saw it I saw you know
when they sent me to galleys or whatever
it was a this is fabulous and I didn't
even think like one of the people at
Salomon Brothers gonna think
except maybe wow they're gonna be so it
they're gonna be think it's so cool that
I wrote an article in The Wall Street
Journal I got to work the next day and
there's a fellow who was who ran all of
Salomon Brothers International
delightful guy who's the guy who had
hired me in the first place and he was
ashen-faced sitting at my desk with this
little newspaper on his lap and he said
Michael I mean it was really written sad
nothing's anger and it was more in
sadness he says Michael you've no no
idea of the damage you've done and I was
kinda like what do you mean he said he
said this thing is being picked up all
over the United States and we've had a
crisis meeting overnight of the Salomon
Brothers Board what to do about it
they couldn't have wouldn't have fired
me because I had just fluke Elise tarted
to generate a whole lot of money for
them like a whole lot of money I had the
second biggest money I was essentially a
salesperson and I had at that point the
second biggest money generating account
in the entire firm and the person would
speak only to me even though even though
I had only been there a year and a half
and it was a it was a it was this
basically the most sophisticated hedge
fund sort of manager in Europe and he
was doing all kind so they didn't want
to they wouldn't fire me because I
didn't lose him so he said to me my boss
said what are we gonna do about this and
I said I don't really wanna do anything
about this and he said
well well it's we need you to stop
writing and I said I'm not gonna stop
writing you know it's what I love to do
and he's and he had the bright idea he
said could you write it under a
different name and I said no problem
yeah I can through that and he said what
name you're gonna use and I actually
just popped into my head I'll use my
mother's maiden name so I wrote under
the name Diana Bleeker for maybe the
next nine months or a year maybe not
quite that long but I wrote half a dozen
pieces that were they got better and
better I was getting better and better
because I had better and better editing
so Michael Kinsley at the who was then
editing the New Republic had walked into
my life and he was he was teach giving
me riding lessons basically in the way
he edited the pieces but but the pieces
Diana Bleeker was writing I mean I
really felt off the leash because nobody
could trace it back to me you know I was
almost describing the trading floor
around me in pieces and people were
circulating it was really great I
sitting in London at my desk doing my
business and I would watch people
xeroxing articles I'd written in the New
Republic under Dianna Bleeker and pass
them out on the trading floor and so I
had I had a sense that like god people
are hungry for this people laughing
people were it was just working now the
money part of it what happened was I
came home one night to my house in
London picked up a phone call and it was
a man named Ned chase who happens to be
Chevie chases dad who was a senior
editor at Simon & Schuster and he said I
figured out who Diana bleaker was and I
got your number I never found out how he
did that and and I think we think you
should write a book and at that point I
thought I'm out if someone will if
someone will publish a book by me I'm
gonna hang around The Wall Street firm
any longer I I did hang around in extra
three months to get my bonus but the
minute the but the minute I saw the
money hit the bank account and I knew
they couldn't take it back I left and it
not because I you know disliked them it
was just I loved a lot of the guys there
mostly it was almost all guys I really
liked my bosses generally i I just was
bored with the word
and I had this other thing I love to do
and it was not the only you know I had
two conversations that in which people
tried to say oh don't do that don't walk
away from a sure fortune to go take a
flyer on writing a book
one was my bosses who took me into a
room and this tells you just how
innocent in age it was I mean these days
you'd be in a room with lawyers right
and and you'd be sick told you sign this
non-disclosure agreement and you're
writing anything about anything they
didn't care about it they were worried
about my sanity they were actually
worried about my career they couldn't
believe that I was gonna walk away from
this really cushy situation and go and
do that other thing so they were trying
to help me and I just said you know I
got it I got this feeling I got to do
this and my father my father said you
know you really could just wait you
really could just collect some millions
of dollars and then write your books but
the problem was I was what 27 at the
time I looked ahead of me and I looked
at people who were 35 or 37 and they
seemed ancient and they seemed
completely stuck like they made so much
money and their lives had adapted to the
making of money they depended on the
making of money and I just thought
there's no way I'd spend a lot of time
here and still even want to do this I
just wrapped and I don't want to do that
so I ignored all that advice and just
wouldn't did it and and it worked out
you know it was like that was Liars that
was liars poker liars poker at least
I've read was intended to be a
cautionary tale of sorts it's not not
how everybody took it I mean it's a very
exciting exciting book you know it was
it was the thing is it's a it's like a
funny book it was a funny story very
very funny book and it's and it's also
an incredible but story because you're
seeing this this transformation of this
industry and the effect on all these
young people but but I thought of it I
had one I had only one kind of
moralistic a thought in mind when I
wrote it because I really just thought
my models that I had in my head when I
wrote it
were hit education of Henry Adams and
Rousseau's confessions and it with the
model was just tell the world what
happened exactly as you remember it and
that's enough you don't need to layer on
an interpretation of what happened what
happens good enough and and the extent I
wanted kind of to push the reader in any
direction it was just really young
readers like people in college that I
hoped would read it and would say yeah I
now know what this is yeah there's money
there but a lot of its kind of silly and
I have these other things I want to do
with my life and I'm gonna go do them so
I'm not going to be seduced by goldman
sachs when i'm walking or bor have you
know goldman sachs prey on my anxiety
about my future when i'm walking out of
my college I'm gonna I'm gonna go do
what I'm meant to do and I felt that way
because I had watched classmates at
Princeton just naturally drift into the
arms of the investment banks because
they really couldn't they felt they
couldn't resist the money and they were
anxious about not being successes now
course then what happens is the book
comes out and the book makes it seem
because it was as business goes
incredibly colorful and entertaining and
lucrative and I had I had this I mean
like dozens of letters a day from young
readers saying dear mr. Lewis I really
loved your how-to book about Wall Street
about how to make money on Wall Street
and I'm hoping that there's some tips in
there that you didn't put in there that
you could let me know so I have an edge
and it just it just it's it just it just
fueled the the desire of young people to
want to do it more and I didn't see that
coming and that's something I don't know
anybody writes books I think learns that
you write a book but the reader reads a
book and the reader may read a book
that's entirely different from what you
thought you wrote and you can't you
can't really do that much about it how
do you think how do you
about if you do ambition in and this may
not be a good question but it seems like
from what I've read the over ambition
that kind of people wear on their
shirtsleeves in certainly many parts of
Wall Street you you find off-putting or
maybe in bad taste but you certainly
don't shy away from ambitious projects
right how do you think how do you
personally think about ambitious not and
I don't want to put put words in your
mouth either no no it's an interesting
way to frame the question how do I think
about ambition well I could tell you I
thought it was so comical
that I was going to be in this ambitious
money-making world that the week before
I went to Salomon Brothers I went into
Paul Stewart because I saw this men's
store because I saw it through their
window I saw they had red suspenders
with a little gold dollar signs on them
and I thought this is a way this is like
a way to make fun of the whole thing
and nobody thought it was funny nobody
thought it was like you can't wear that
[ __ ] around here
you know into you you can't wear that
[ __ ] until you are a big enough deal to
wear that's that [ __ ] you know you can't
and but but it was I've always thought
I've always been enormous ly ambitious
in a way I well I've always wanted my
life to be great like really great I
mean at this very moment every evening I
tell my children we're gonna win the
pandemic I that I'm competitive
like very competitive and I love
competitive sports I love winning I
don't particularly like losing but I
don't I guess number one I don't accept
money as an accurate measure or any kind
of real measure of whether you're
winning and losing
so I never sow money didn't doesn't hold
that that kind of doesn't have that hold
on me Fame a bit more I mean I would say
a lust for attention and and fame is is
probably closer to a vice of mine than a
lust for money and fortune
but but even that I get I finally get
tired of and and it just doesn't
interest me that much so I don't I'm not
a I don't think I'm a Maximizer in that
I'm not trying to like I'm not trying to
not trying to get a lot of a thing it's
more if I'm trying to maximize anything
it's a it's a feeling and it's a feeling
that like that like that was a kick-ass
book that was that was just that I could
look at something and just say that is a
great piece of work that feeling is what
I am what kind of always gunning for and
it's a pretty private feeling and I
think over time I mean you must have
found this - that the response that I
have to external validation has become
muted and numbed and when I got a
glowing review for liars poker and it
went to the top of the New York Times
bestseller list
it's like dancing all over my kitchen I
mean I was just happy as a clam I
couldn't believe I mean I've just did it
was like I just won the Super Bowl and
now I don't read the reviews I sometimes
forget whether a book is on the New York
Times bestseller list or not I mean I
just don't I'm not paying as much
attention to it and it's not eight
because it's not able it doesn't it
doesn't gratify me in the same way but
the gratification I get from looking at
something that I think I've done that's
really good is this is is at least as
great as it was back then so I think
that's I think I'm tapping into that
it's I'm do you think I'm tapping into
like the pleasure I got when I was just
all by myself in a room laughing at my
own jokes it's sort of like maximizing
self satisfaction maybe not maybe not
the most attractive trait that that my
ambition is to maximize my self
satisfaction but maybe that's maybe
that's my ambition well let's let's jump
into the the process associated with the
self setting the self satisfaction you
mentioned laughing at your own jokes I
have read that you sometimes write late
at night
say midnight you put on a headset and
play the same soundtrack of say 20 songs
over and over again is that something
that you still do yes in fact I did it
yesterday I I don't
kids screwed up my natural writing
rhythm my natural rhythm would be to
kind of start about 4:00 in the
afternoon
and write till 3:00 in the morning and
and sleep until noon but you can't do
that with kids so I so I now I'm not as
likely to be found late at night at my
desk though it happens sometimes but
whenever I'm writing I have headphones
on and I have a soundtrack I write to
and the soundtrack changes but it
changes book to book and it's got to the
point where both my wife and my kids
will will recommend songs for the
soundtrack and for whatever the next
project is and I'll build a soundtrack
out of out of intentionally and the
music is you know it's all over the map
it tends to be very up but it tends to
be music that that I just stopped
hearing and I noticed something really
funny just just the last couple of weeks
because I'm working on something now the
second season of my podcast where I have
a different relation to music the the
podcast is about coaching and in the
last episode which I have still not
written it's the only episode I haven't
written is me getting coached in
something I'm incredibly uncomfortable
doing and it's singing I've been I've
been doing voice lessons for the every
an hour every day for the last three
months and there's a song I sing and I'm
I can tell you which one it is that I'm
gonna have to sing that I've been
practicing that happens to be on my
soundtrack and now I realize I have to
remove it because it kicks my brain in a
different space all of a sudden I hear
it and it's like Pavlovian I've got to
belt out the tune I've got to worry
about hitting a high note and it screws
up my writing and so I've just been
hitting skip it went when it but because
I've been reluctant to change it but I
have to just gonna have to remove it and
it's the minute so it puts me the music
puts me in the purpose of it is to shut
out the possibility of interruption that
I can't hear knocks on the door phones
people dropping packages on the front
porch anything it's just it's I'm just
in my own space and I just and I kind of
ceased to hear the sound could you uh
there's part of me that really hopes to
god that that song is a whole new world
on the Aladdin soundtrack but I don't
know why I just I can't wait for that
accent oh you wait you wouldn't rather
be let it go from frozen
I'll take let it go I will do you
remember the soundtracks that you used
for specific books I mean if if we were
to pick or could you give an example of
some of the component tracks from any
book that you've worked on you know
what's funny is I bet if you just ask me
that way the answer is no I could make
stuff up but but if a song comes on then
I wrote say The Blind Side - I'll
remember that was on the soundtrack for
the Blind Side God and so I don't have a
I mean it's almost the point of them is
that I'm not really listening to them so
there are there songs that I would have
listened to a thousand times and I don't
know the words because I'm not really
paying attention to them I'm paying
attention something else
it's it's a device for shutting out
other interruption and for creating kind
of an emotion a feeling but it's so so
the answer is I don't but I take what I
have saved that in the old in olden
times there was a thing called a CD that
you had to have to play music and and in
those olden times I would save the CD
and just toss it in a folder or you know
put it away and keep sector or so I have
the old soundtracks oh boy well that
that could be a tremendous bonus if you
want to get anyone to any website of
your choosing the soundtrack to
Moneyball oh my god
yeah it's like Johnny Cash it make no
sense right right yeah you mentioned you
mentioned coaches I want to talk about
and and we'll see if we can get into
specifics maybe maybe not but you
mentioned Michael was it Kinsley is that
right he editor yeah or the New Republic
yeah what made him a good editor or what
did you learn from him can you remember
anything that he helped tighten or
improve so Michael Kinsley had a gift
for creating writers there there dozens
of people who were young writers then
who he had profound influence on and
careers that he just launched I mean and
it's an odd assortment and I was one of
those people and what he so what I think
what happens with writers who come up in
a conventional way like through creative
writing programs or by writing for their
circle of friends is they get treated to
politely their work gets treated to
politely and so they don't hear a really
withering critique of their work and
Michael Kinsley could not help himself
he delivered the most withering
critiques of your work and so if you the
fun the kind of throat-clearing
phony first paragraph which was totally
unnecessary he would come back and be a
bit of big X through it why did you even
write that start here it would be I
can't remember I you I had learned a
word that was just a completely obscure
word and I even remember the word but I
don't know how to pronounce it it's
Athenian it starts CH and I think it's I
think it means of the underworld and and
I remember I remember working it working
it into the piece and like a big circle
around it saying you [ __ ] phony you
know what do you do you know you would
you would you do go into the thesaurus
it was just like making making merciless
fun of me and even with my by the firt
my byline at the very beginning I
thought it
sounded good it was referred to be
Michael M Lewis my middle name is Monroe
I thought a middle initial kind of dance
heated up and he put a big circle around
it and he said don't do that you know
don't be one of those people you're not
you're not Michael Emmylou you're
Michael Luke and yes he just he he was
all the preposterous things that you
naturally tend to do when you're putting
you know words on paper he identified
all of them and as as vices and stops
you from them and so that was in
addition he was unbelievably gifted at
seeing what a good story was so you saw
what was kind of you started to learn
what was interesting him what wasn't
just talking to him just by how he
responded to what you said it was a kind
of feedback that everybody should get
but that most people are too tender and
sensitive to deliver it's a funny thing
I think that this happens in speech - I
think that lots there's lots of
inefficiency in human conversation
there's that that people do all kinds of
things they really shouldn't do and that
that other people make fun of them for
doing people are endlessly telling
stories about what some other person
said making fun of them and the the and
the reason and it shouldn't be that way
we should be very efficient
conversationalist because we do it all
the time but we art because we don't get
feedback because people are too polite
and I think people are too polite with
other people's writing and what Michael
Kinsley his great gift in addition to be
a kind of genius was a he just couldn't
be polite he was just so blunt and so so
as I really I mean I I'm now I'm Michael
Lewis on my books instead of Michael M
Lewis because of Michael Kinsley that's
yeah that's I remember up in one of my
freshmen wasn't freshmen it was a
seminar though at at Princeton and not
to imply that it in any way hold a
candle to McPhee but took this seminar
with John McPhee and he I remember when
he returned the papers our initial
writing assignments to the 12 students
in the class
he effectively had to preface it by
saying I don't want you to be shocked
and I'm paraphrasing here you're all
decent writers or good writers so don't
you know take take this as constructive
feedback and I got back my two pages it
was really short and there was more red
ink than the black ink I'd used to type
it up and there's a just an incredible
piece or at I think a series of
interviews in the Paris Review on the
art of nonfiction where he talks about
you know describing things as pea soup
and it's just like a big circle that
kind of points out the obvious right and
so that the the benefit of impolite
feedback has just been so tremendous in
my life as well yeah and people it's
nice just to have people not tiptoe
around the problem because and then you
you once it said you know you you know
that that little middle initial in mind
in my byline that there's a little faux
ninis there and I just did I just hope
nobody would notice they just they just
take me is more important and well
that's that's interesting that you were
in McPhee's writing class because I was
a big McPhee fan when I was at Princeton
but it never even occurred to me I just
assumed I could never even get into that
class so I didn't apply it was because
that was a hard class to get into it was
I mean I I will say that I maybe this is
I mean it's certainly been advantageous
to me I suppose there when when I feel
like I don't have any chance of getting
into something it removes the
performance anxiety mm-hmm if that makes
any sense it makes total sense and
therefore I was just completely
unattached to outcomes because I assumed
that I would get rejected and the
literature of fact I still have I still
have my notes from undergrad my all my
binders full of notes from two classes
the literature of fact and high-tech
entrepreneurship with a professor named
Ed Chou I still have my notes from those
two classes they've traveled with me for
twenty years I don't I mean now there's
draft number four in other books that
kind of describe McPhee's mess
I refer to them less but what a it was
real gift I mean ya know III it's part
of me is glad I didn't take that class
because I think I think he might have he
might have persuaded me that I wasn't a
writer I don't think I was ready for it
that I had to kind of find my own way
but but because he was an intimidating
figure and he's so good at what he did
but the but I I wished with McPhee I
wished he spent more time writing about
people because he did it so well that
book he did on Brad Bill Bradley was an
incredible piece of work yeah a sense of
where you are great book but anyway so
he does spend a lot of time writing
about oranges and rocks and canoes and
all manner of other non-human objects
you know it's it's an impressive he
pulls it off but he's so good he was so
good about people I wish there was more
of it anyway I have a question for you
about maybe this isn't the right word
but productive laziness I was looking at
an article that talked about a speaking
gig from 2017 Qualtrics you might you
might might know where this is going but
the quote that stuck out to me was
attributed to you people waste years of
their lives not being willing to waste
hours of their lives and I don't know if
that prompts any memories but is that
something you can elaborate on sure that
wasn't a quote for me it was a quote
from one of my characters Amos risky it
was one of the main characters in the
undoing project and he but that it
resonated with me what he meant was that
that people don't back away from their
work they and especially the need to
always seem busy or be busy stops people
from from finding things that are really
worth doing and sifting the ones that
are worth doing from the ones that
aren't worth doing so and that so it
resonates with me because I am NOT a
person who always has to be doing
something and in fact mine at
Trull state is probably inert that I can
really just lay around and screw off and
procrastinate and and with the best of
them and and and it's partly because I
grew up I mean I grew up in New Orleans
and and there was not a whole lot of
value attached to am either ambition or
career achievement you you were who you
were because of how you were and who
your family was and what neighborhood
you grew up in and where he went to
school you were always so well defined
by your environment that trying to
change it by doing stuff didn't seem to
make a whole lot of sense and I you know
my father used to tell me and it was it
was he would tell and I believe this
until I was about 20 that on our family
coat of arms there was a motto in Latin
in the motto was do as little as
possible and that unwillingly for it is
better to receive a slight reprimand
than to perform an arduous task and and
he would just say that like you know
just keep that in mind we live by these
words and and and if so that's my you
know kind of where I was coming from
just generally and and I found this
thing that didn't feel like work so it
didn't feel like an attempt at
achievement not that achievement was bad
it just that's not why I was doing it
but but having said that you know I do
find that being able to back away and
get yourself myself in a state of mind
in which I can say it's okay if I never
write anything else it's okay if I never
ride in another book it's okay if I
don't do anything for six months and I
can afford that now and that's nice to
be it's a luxury to be able to afford it
but I think a lot of people who can
afford it don't don't actually take
advantage of the luxury because I think
that doing that putting yourself in a
state of mind where alright I'm I've got
I've got to make an argument about why I
need to write another book because I
don't have to
changes your relationship to potential
stories and potential material
it requires the material to rise to the
level of interest where you feel obliged
to engage with it so you're not doing it
just because you got to write another
book you're doing it because how can I
not write this and it it serves my own
sloth and indolence serves as a kind of
filter and the filter is you know I
don't you know no I don't have to do
that so I'm not gonna do that I don't
particularly want to do that so I just
not going to do that and even if you
tell me that oh it's got big bestseller
written all over it I'm not interested
because it keeps me off that path and
that that I think it's been very useful
because it does two things at once
one is I see it raises the level of the
bar that the material has to jump over
to get to me so the material is going to
have to be really good if I'm going to
engage with it and two it stops me from
doing the same thing over and over again
just to be successful it enables me to
it almost encourages me to move around
and do surprising things and I think
readers and audiences really appreciate
and and will engage with the writer
who's willing to take risks that yeah
they like they're right at somewhere
their writers to just keep doing the
same things over and over again but but
they'll they'll follow you if you if you
take a brave risk since I'm not doing it
I'm not trying to create the next
surefire bestseller I'm led to other and
sometimes unlikely material and the
books are kind of so the books end up
being about a lot of different things
what are some of the the questions or
thresholds that indicate the material
has risen past risen above the necessary
hurdles I found one question I don't
know if this is you or not so feel free
to confirm or deny but you know would I
be sad if this story didn't get told
yeah that's that's
it's funny that's that is one and it's
it's a it's a it's a really good
question because there's not a clear-cut
rule that I follow except feeling and
there are a couple of feelings that I
associate with the desire to write a
book one is a feeling that if I don't do
it it won't properly get done because I
have some privileged access to the story
and there are lots of different ways you
can have privileged access to the story
but the sense that that yeah this book
really should be written and someone
needs to do it and that someone is
clearly me and so that the second and
related feeling is I I have an
obligation to the material it isn't the
material has an obligation to me as a
writer it's I have an obligation to this
material and once I have that feeling I
have a motive I have a motive and
whether I'm fooling myself or not it's a
it's a it's a motive that's a deeper and
more inspiring motive and aha I got to
make a living or oh I got to get a book
on the bestseller list or you know I
gotta have something to tell my friends
when they asked me what are you doing
it's it's it's a motive that like it's
the highest motive its I have an
obligation I have a duty and and so I've
had that feeling with every book I've
written and and again how did how it
gets to that point I mean they take
their different paths to that point but
it obviously is it's some feeling in
myself that this is an important story
could you give an example of the feeling
a duty or obligation to the material
you mentioned the undoing project you
could give an example from any of your
books but what what concretely what is
what might that look like if you are the
obligation or duty to the material well
it really could take any book but let's
take let's take Moneyball just to mix
things up so that Moneyball starts not
as a book Moneyball starts as a as a
question that I ate and the end isn't
even a good question
and the question was how pissed off is
the leftfielder are the of the Oakland
A's when the right fielder drops the
flyball because the right fielder is now
making four times as much money as the
left fielder I wondered I was wondering
about the effects sort of the class
dynamics on a professional baseball team
now that salaries had blown up and there
were some people getting paid huge sums
of money much and there was huge
inequality on inside of a baseball team
and that that caused me to watch the
games kind of watching the money and not
just watching the games and then I saw
the inequality that was interesting was
not that between the players it was
because they didn't seem to be resentful
of each other at all it was between the
teams and that you had these this poor
team in my backyard the Oakland A's and
they had to play against teams at four
or five times the sums of money to spend
on players and how are they winning more
games in those teams and then I it then
it becomes a magazine piece in my mind
because I go to see Billy Beane the
general manager the Oakland A's and and
he says huh you know you're asking me
the single most important question in my
life and no one has asked me that which
key says that tells you something about
sports journalism he says nobody's asked
me how we're thinking about distributing
the money over the players and how we're
making these sort of investments in
assets and how we're thinking a lot like
Wall Street traders and he started to
fill my ear and I thought this is really
interesting really interesting but it's
a magazine piece it's like a magazine
piece about how a general manager thinks
and I started to spend time with him and
where it rose to the level of not
magazine piece but this is a long story
worthy of a book was when I began to
realize that what the Oakland A's were
doing was looking for value in people
that the people that sometimes even
themselves did not appreciate and the
market certainly didn't appreciate and
that was why these people could be could
be acquired cheaply people happened to
be baseball players but they really
could be anything and and the moment it
was really a moment sometimes there are
these moments
moment when I thought oh my god this is
a book was when I had I was interviewing
the players after games I would see them
pick a player after every I'd say Scott
Hatteberg I'll meet you after the game
at your locker and he'd say okay I'll
give you twenty minutes then Barry Zito
you know one thing it was moving around
the clubhouse and and the player I was
watching the players come out of the
showers and I'd so it was the first time
I really noticed them naked and they
were so appalling they were so
unpleasant to look at they were fat they
were misshapen in various ways they do
not look like professional they look
like they really they just you would
never guess they were professional
athletes and but I saved this to the to
the front office of the A's I say the
next day I said you know I was just want
you the bodies of your guys it's so it's
awful like and and Paul DePodesta who
was the number two said that's kind of
the point he says we go looking for
people who the market doesn't value a
pre doesn't doesn't appreciate and one
of the ways that blunt and one of the
things that blinds the market to the
value of a baseball player is the
physical appearance of the player an
ugly player is likely to be cheaper than
a handsome player a very a guy who looks
like a professional athlete is likely to
be valued he's the people gonna see his
value with blinds the market if they
don't look right so we're looking for
players who don't look right and I
thought at that moment the reason it's
worthy of a book and the reason I have
an obligation to the story is this isn't
about baseball anymore this is about
this is a universal truth about the way
markets value people that you have this
market it just happens to be baseball
where of all markets on the planet you
would think would value people properly
they've been doing the same job for a
hundred years
they've got statistics attached to every
move they make on a field they've got
millions of people watching them on the
job most of who think they know exactly
what a good baseball player is and what
isn't if those people can be so miss
valued that baseball a baseball team is
run
circles around other baseball teams by
picking up the ones who who look wrong
then who can't be that it was the story
and it became a very universal story
about about the mistakes we make when we
look at another person and at that point
I thought it was gay it was gold I just
thought this is just the most
magnificent it's a truth I know in my
life I've watched people be miss value
in my whole life
I've watched people get paid way more
than they deserve I've got people
getting paid way less than they deserve
I've seen people in teams go entirely
unappreciated who are extremely
important to the team and people who
took all the credit and they actually
weren't that important and I've seen
this through my whole life and now I'm
seeing it expressed in this very
interesting little microcosm and and I
have an obligation to explain that to
the world I'd like to ask about
something that popped up at least once
maybe more than once when I was
preparing for this and that is the
comment that Michael is one of the
happiest people I know and I I said
let's see here it was the author of a
Washington Post piece I have oh I bet it
was I bet it was Walter Isaacson eight
know what it might have been Walter
Isaacson yeah and so I'd be curious if
you agree with that and if you do is
that something you kind of deduced your
way into being that is a happy person or
was that sort of hardwired from genetics
and upbringing in family-oriented New
Orleans how do you how would you comment
on to this statement so they're two
they're two answers one is I really have
always been a a conspicuously happy
person even in even in the gloomy years
of my life when I was kind of like in
middle school and causing trouble and I
can remember the headmaster at the
Newman school who prevented me from
getting thrown out of the school a
couple of years later I was in his
office again because I had insulted the
English
and geez I'd actually planned my insult
I thought it was such a clever thing to
say she was she was notoriously
unpleasant to students and she said
something kind of sharp to me
and I said dr. Frances are you always so
pleasant to be with or is this just an
especially good day for you and she said
she'll I just pointed to the door like
go to headmaster here's a note you know
and and I got and and when I repeated
what I had done yes I like in the ninth
grade at this point I was 13 or 14 the
headmaster you could see he was like
cracking up he was just like he knew he
was supposed to punish me they just
started he just started laughing because
he had the same feelings about the
English teacher and it could not and he
said you know my he said come Michael
Lewis he said I've been watching you
around this place for like 10 years and
you're like that you're like one of the
happiest people I have ever met but you
can't be doing this [ __ ] and he said we
you know we have to agree we've got to
control it in various ways the spirit is
high in you but you've got we've got to
control it and and he was just and when
he said that you know you're like one of
the heaviest people I've ever met
I hadn't occurred to me because I think
when you're happy you know it when
you're unhappy I don't know it so much
when you're at but when you're happy you
just kind of take it for granted but
that was from that moment on I didn't
take it for granted I thought you know
he's right that I am basically really
happy even when even when things aren't
going so great and and I like that I
liked that self definition so I've I
sought to preserve it now as I've gotten
older I would say starting in kind of my
mid to late 20s I could not help but
notice the effect on people of the
stories they told about themselves if
you listen to people if you just sit and
listen you'll find that their patterns
in the way they talk about themselves
there's the kind of person who is always
the victim in any story that they tell
always on the receiving end of some
injustice
there the person who's always kind of a
hero of every story they tell the smart
person they deliver the you know the
clever put down there are lots of
versions of this and you gotta be very
careful about how you tell these stories
because it starts to become you you are
in the way you craft your narrative kind
of crafting your character and so I did
at some point decide I'm gonna I am
going to adopt self-consciously
as my narrative then I'm the happiest
person anybody knows and it is amazing
how happy inducing it is and it also you
know there is this I don't know if you
notice this in your life but lots of
intelligent people when they start a
conversation with you if they're trying
to be sensitive sort of like how are you
doing I mean it must be this must be a I
know you're in the middle of finishing a
book or your or your kid just got got
punished at school or or I saw you had a
fight with your wife or whatever it is I
know that something must be wrong then a
lot of people open to conversations by
giving you an opportunity to complain
and sure that they don't even do that
with me anymore so we get we don't even
start there all my friends would they
would even bother
like like what because they know I'm not
going to go there and it's it's terrific
it's just terrific it's not like starts
every conversation off on a delightful
cheery foot and so so if it is partly
hardwired and partly self conscious
partly partly a kind of a personality
trait and partly a trait that I've just
tried to really encourage in myself
well let me dig in to the friend
exchange because there there might be
something I can emulate here so if
they've been trained if they've been
trained not to give you the floor to
complain by giving these very common
prompts what type of question would they
open with like I said is it a good or a
great day Michael or do they have know
that I would like to practice not that
I'm bitching and moaning all the time I
would like to
think I'm not but how do you guys start
your conversations well something
entirely differently like let's go have
an adventure or I what's the last great
idea what you you know I think about my
friends who were just in my life here in
Berkeley it would be it's it's like
alright what's the cool idea you're
working on or or they start you know
they start it's just the conversation
instantly launches into something
substantive it's not about how I'm
feeling because how I'm feeling is never
interesting so so it's it's a great way
to take how I'm feeling off the table
now there may come a time in my life
where I would like to talk about how I'm
feeling and I'm sure they'll be open to
it but we're not just naturally drifting
into that well we're drifting into
something like like you know just what's
what happened that day
it's it starts on it just starts on a
different footing and I'm usually pretty
bored with people who want to talk about
how they're feeling I hate to say that
so we do so by taking it out it's a
strategic right by taking it off the
table for me I'm taking it off table for
them too
I mean they want to talk about how
they're feeling they can talk to someone
else but unless it's really important
I'd rather do other things I'd rather
talk about so it's always if it's always
a sunny day the weather ceases to be
interesting there's so many questions
that I could follow up with love to I'm
sure that yeah there there there are a
million shrinks out there who think if I
can only get my hands on him I would
scratch below this service and I'd find
the agony but I swear to god they get
scratched for a million years and they
would not find anything but joy and
delight well there goes my plan also for
the next thirty minutes to just give you
a confession of all of my deepest
insecurities but for around two perhaps
we're talking a bit about friends and
you mentioned a name earlier and I might
get the pronunciation wrong here but a
mists verse it's a very mr. Bert Amos
Tversky Tversky and
the undoing project so we have amos and
daniel kahneman
danny kahneman after and maybe you could
provide just a bit of context for people
who don't know who who they are and what
the book was about but my question is if
that informed how you think about
friendship or change how you approach
your friendships in any way so let's
start by explaining who these guys are
so Danny Kahneman and Amos Tversky could
plausibly be credited with creating the
whole Moneyball phenomenon they in that
and I didn't realize this until after I
had written Moneyball
they were the psychologists who
collaborated on essentially a a lifelong
project from both of them exploring the
various ways that human beings
irrational is a word they would have not
have liked to use but the the the
mistakes that people make when they're
making judgments under on conditions of
uncertainty that even when you kind of
create a situation where there is a
statistically correct answer that people
make systematically make the same
mistakes they they they they miss value
risks in all kinds of ways and they
explored the ways they miss valued risks
now what attracted me to this story was
one there was a body of knowledge that I
thought was incredibly important and
that had had had explained why the
market for baseball players for example
was so inefficient that the Oakland A's
could mop up inside of it explain why
Danny Amos in their own way explain why
players who did not look like baseball
players would be miss valued and players
who looked a lot like baseball players
might be overvalued they explain why
like vivid traits like foot speed or
power would be overvalued and subtle
traits that were hard to see would be
undervalued so they've done it
their work was interesting but we
captivated me and we created that sense
of
I got to write this book was the
essential love affair platonic love
affair between the two men they were
opposites in many ways Danny was this
gloomy pessimist and Amos was this very
up optimist
Amos actually had a line that he thought
he would say sometimes to Danny the
pessimism was stupid because when you're
pessimistic you live it twice once when
you're worrying about the bad thing
happening in the second time when it
actually happens why do that he they the
book and so the book explores their
relationship and their dynamic and
explores the power of collaboration like
two people it was intriguing to me that
two people could produce work that was
so one breathtakingly important and two
completely different than what either
one of them would have done on their own
so that's the backdrop to the book in
what your set what was your other
question what was the what my question
was if the process of writing that book
getting to know I'll change my attitude
towards friendship
oh well that's funny so I I did you know
their friendship was very fraught it was
it was like a tempestuous love affair
and on a mice's deathbed Amos said to
Danny no human being has caused me more
agony more misery on the planet than you
and Danny said right even though Amos
was dying Danny said write back to him I
feel the same way about you and they the
so there their friendship is not a
friend it's their relationship they had
is not a relationship I've ever had with
another person that my own friendships
tend to be a lot more stable that they
were incredibly stable actually I have
close friends from when I was 12 and 13
years old who were still some of my
closest friends in the world
and they aren't a lots of ups and downs
in them in throwing of plates and
justice doesn't happen so I don't think
I'm wired
in a way that would come tolerate that
kind of friendship and to some extent
Amos wasn't it drove Amos crazy I saw a
lot of myself in Amos just
temperamentally and what would happen
what would happen with Amos was he
discovered that Danny was the Golden
Goose that that the ideas that they
hatched together were so valuable that
he could tolerate the drama of the
relationship with Danny but otherwise he
had very limited tolerance for drama in
his friendships and I do too
you know I don't it's and it's not that
I don't engage with my friends problems
or engage with their ups and downs but
we tend not to have ups and downs
between us so I can't say that the book
actually has informed any particular
friendship of mine what it has done is
make me appreciate the few friendships I
have where the interaction is leading me
to a much better place as a writer I
have a few people who I talk to about
stuff I'm working on and it just it ends
up so much better because it because of
it and it makes me appreciate that it's
like I'm never these books that I write
I'm never really just doing them myself
that it's not just me that it's this
very complicated collaboration between
me and friends I talk to about it and me
and my subject matter the subjects I
write about are often kind of kind of
co-conspirators in this stuff they give
me ideas sometimes without knowing it so
it's it it has sort of watching knowing
about the relationship between Amos
Tversky and Daniel Kahneman has sort of
informed me about the way the creative
process works mm-hmm with with that
small group of friends you share work
with what types of prompts or questions
do you offer them in the sense that
that what is the request well how do you
phrase your requests and what usually I
mean sometimes it's oh so Jacob Weisberg
is one of them who is the founder of
Pushkin industries the podcast company
but we go all the way back to being
joint disciples of Michael Kinsley at
the New Republic Oh No kidding
didn't have Jacob can point to Michael
is the person who kind of shaped him as
a writer and but with Jacob all to say
all right here here's here's this idea I
have what do you think and I'll lay it
out in five or ten minutes on a hiking
trail or over the phone and what he does
and his great gift is not is not just
say I like it or I don't like it he does
he does this thing and this is the all
the friends I consult are this way
they're all improvisational they also
they all obey the kind of the rules of
improv comedy in conversation that their
first step is never know that's stupid I
have a smart thing to say that puts this
thing you just said in its place their
first step is to try to take what I've
said and build on it or find what's good
in it and Danny Kahneman had this
wonderful line and it's one of my
favorite lines of the book when he is
with his graduate students in a seminar
he's the professor at Hebrew University
in Jerusalem and the students at Hebrew
University are famously caustic who all
want kind of one-upping each other all
the time always seemed trying to seem
like the smart kid in the room and he
says to the students at his first
seminar he says when someone in this
room says something don't ask if it's
true ask what might it be true of where
what what value might there be in that
thing that was said don't try to show me
how smart you are by showing how stupid
everybody else is
show me how smart you are by showing me
how smart everybody else is and my my my
closest friend collaborators the people
who just listen to me the sounding
boards are often showing me how smart I
am in that they're sort of taking
something that I sense and they go
and yes and it leads me some other place
so that's the way that's the way the
conversation usually sounds and I'll go
oh my god I hadn't thought of it that
way or I was thinking of that way I'm
glad you find it interesting that it's
it's uh but it's that's the nature of it
and that's that's it's just have you
ever been have you ever done it it tried
to do improv comedy I have and as many
years ago in San Francisco and it was
surprisingly difficult yes it's like me
too I found it surprisingly difficult
exactly and and but it felt like a
muscle that you could exercise and I
think everybody should exercise because
it is amazing what happens if you listen
to people in a generous way and you're
looking for the thing they're saying
that's useful where that leads you is
often just magical
and the when you're watching really good
improv comedians what they do seems like
magic and sometimes I feel like with my
friends that they that they they kind of
introduce that magic into my mind hmm
well let's let's talk about you
mentioned
pushkin the name so you have it
critically acclaimed Pushkin produced
podcast against the rules and you have a
new season which I'll leave it to you to
describe but maybe we could use as an
entry point an episode which which I was
able to listen to in advance this
episode three inner coach and my
question is what was it like having a
long conversation with Timothy Galway
and maybe who is Timothy gone with for
those who don't know and then what was
it like having a long conversation with
him because I only heard snippets which
were fantastic yeah I'll let you taste
it from there
so first the said the episode so the
season is that this this is the second
season of against the rules and the
first season was about referees and the
role of referees
American life the second season is about
coaches and the role of coaches in
American life and the the general idea
of the podcast that is cooked up with
Jacob Weisberg is to look at to take
various authority figures in our lives
and figures the authority figures whose
status role use has changed in some way
and kind of explore why that changes
happenin and what it means and so the
episode you're talking about is is about
this whole idea of the inner game of
things that the whole notion that you
can coach that when you coach something
what you really should be coaching is
states of mind and kim galway is really
the founding father this idea he wrote
he was at he was a tennis pro at a kind
of upper-middle class tennis club in
california who notices that it kind of
in an accidental way that when he
doesn't give instruction people are
learning more rapidly how to play tennis
than when he does give instruction then
when he doesn't tell them where to put
their racket or when to hit the ball or
where to hit the ball that they're kind
of they're kind of getting it quicker
just by just by emulating him just by
watching him and to the extent he's
giving them instruction he is he's not
telling he's he's telling them to focus
on like their core strengths or their
breath or something away from the the
the end result and when he sees this
when he sees the effect of this sort of
instruction he he starts to kind of
build a program of instruction around
and he has of writing a book called the
inner game of tennis which is a very
famous book now it's sold millions of
copies but when it was published was
published in whatever 1970 to 1973 by
Random House they told him that was
going to sell 20,000 copies because
that's what tennis book sold and it
turned out that it applied and he
discovers that this stuff he's doing
applies
to coaching anything that if you can if
you can get if you can redirect a
person's attention away from things they
get to kind of cause them to freeze up
or tense up and towards things that sort
of let them flow as they're doing the
thing that it has amazing effects and he
real any right after he publishes his
book he's invited to to the Houston
Philharmonic the few stand Symphony
brings him in with the idea of exploring
whether the principles in the inner game
of Kenneth's might be used to make
musicians play better and the the
conductor is very skeptical of this but
everybody's kind of interested in his
book and so he gives a little talk about
book and they give him a little flight
round of applause and then and then the
conductor says anybody that I want to be
coached by Tim and Tim doesn't know
anything about music I mean he's just
nothing he's kind of got a tin ear he
doesn't know he could hardly can hardly
name the instruments but the tuba player
raises his hand and the tuba player yeah
he asked the tuba player some questions
like like what are you doing when you're
playing the tuba and the guy says I'm
trying to hear the sound so I I you know
I know that I've hit the note that I've
and there's a particular note he had
trouble hitting and and he said it's
hard to hear the sound and I'm straining
and Galway says that's to himself he
says that's like the tennis player who's
who's thinking too much about when the
ball hits the racket or where the racket
is when he's bringing it back so he says
the two places how do you would it
what's going on in your body when it
tends to go well and the tuba player
says it's my tongue my tongue and when
my tongue is moist that the note tends
to be cleaner and so Galway says okay
first play play something and he plays
something and then he says all right now
we're gonna focus just on your tongue I
don't want you to think about the notes
you're playing I just think about the
tongue and keeping it moist and so the
guy then belts out his tuba song again
and the whole Orchestra stands up and
gives him a standing ovation and go it
was funny because he couldn't hear the
difference he said it was just like it's
all tuba you know hey I couldn't tell
whether it was good to bore a bad tuba
but the but the musicians could
completely hear the difference
and yeah so I tell I spent a few hours
with Tim Galway talking about him but
talking to him about this beginning of
an approach to coaching things the inner
game of stuff where you aren't you're
you're almost explicitly avoiding
criticism or praise anything that makes
the performer feel self-conscious and
directing their attention to something
else and and then just explore the
spread of this in all kinds of odd
directions and in this particular
episode one of the things I do is take
someone who is already young but pretty
accomplished as a they're not called
performance coaches a performance coach
and I hire him to coach mice than
seventeen-year-old daughter to play
softball
she's a softball player but she's got as
she says I'm in my head a lot and she's
playing at a very high level and he just
starts kind of working with her and so I
get to kind of watch the process in real
time and her her softball coach sounds
to me at least like the the verbal
equivalent of the written feedback from
Michael King yeah so this is exactly
right so this is exactly right it's and
and it's I come to to the extent that
podcasts it really has seven different
stories all kind of it's it's like a
it's like a symphony it's seven
different instruments on the same theme
and it but it's but I come to the
conclusion that I think maybe Galway
isn't completely right that there is a
role there's for some kind for more than
one kind of coaching but it is true that
my daughter has a female big-time
softball coach she's playing for one of
the best teams in the country and it is
and we wire up her coach and what comes
out of the coach's mouth is
you know you suck
if you suck you'll be on the bench you
know explicit instructions it's just
kind of the opposite of but but the
curious thing is my daughter says I got
a lot out of working with the
performance coach and the inner game
stuff but I also get a lot out of this
other kind of coach to that that that
she's kind of this other kind of coach
has gotten me caring more and now what I
need to do is get kind of through that
voice that's enter my head that she's
put in my head to push me and and start
to ignore it ignore it when I'm at the
plate facing a 70 mile an hour fastball
that that I've got to I've got to kind
of be in a different headspace so
watching her wrestle kind of trying to
fuse these two was very interesting it's
I found them I found the the forum story
to it's essentially long-form radio
storytelling a really intriguing forum
it's been it's been a fun experiment
that has in in in funny ways informed
come back and inform my writing it's it
and you reach as you know a contol you
reach with a with a piece of prose when
you produce one of these podcasts it is
incredible and disheartening in some
ways to look at the well I mean I guess
in my case I'll speak just for myself
that you know buy your books have been
blockbusters my books have done decently
well but the reach with the podcast at a
point is it's just incredible to see
what can be imparted to how many people
on a weekly basis and for that reason
you know I there's part of me that was
that was wondering as as you were just
talking you know have have we lost
Michael to the dark side has he has he
into the void of of audio where where
the the the allure of the written word
will just lose its luster I I don't how
I hope that's not even something like
that you're thinking about I don't know
I think of it as literary cross-training
that I that I'm going to be I'm a better
I'll be a better prose writer because
I'm I'm
working out these other muscles and and
I I'm still writing books I'm still
gonna write books and maybe fewer
long-form
magazine stuff just but and that's
partly because there's just fewer places
to do it but the books for sure are
gonna happen just like they've always
happened but the the being made more
sensitive to sound the sound of the
words on the page the way the different
ways you might read a particular
sentence is a really healthy exercise so
it's just it's just an addition rather
than a substitute and if something has
to give like if I'm doing less of
something maybe slightly fewer along
four magazine pieces and slightly fewer
film scripts which was I was also always
doing which is another way way to
exercise kind of muscle and kind of
cross train as a writer I think it's
really good useful for writers to write
different forms I think that it would
probably be good for me to make myself
trying to write poems every now and then
and it would probably be good for my for
me to try to force myself to write some
fiction every now and then you're good
for the thing I do best which is the
long-form you know book length kind of
story talent nonfiction storytelling and
there's nothing wrong with doing new
stuff and it and it's the other side of
it again this it's not a substitute as
just in addition is it's really a
different experience playing a team
sport than playing in an individual
sport writing a book is an individual
sport you're basically on your own you
have you have help you have coaches your
fans but you're kind of out there pole
vaulting on your own and making a
podcasts the kind of podcast I make it
really is more like a basketball team
that and and I have an incredibly gifted
like editor and producers and I mean
Malcolm Gladwell sits in on my table
reads and Jacob Weisberg I've got I've
got the like ingenious people giving me
feedback I'll add every level of the
process and that's that's fun it's it's
fun because
it's educational and everybody's there
not rude but they're pretty blunt with
how they feel about things and pretty
withholding of praise so I'm getting I'm
getting like the straightest criticism I
ever get and it's it's cool it's just
fun it's fun to do it sounds like fun
I'm I'm I'm mostly although I have a
very good team in support I do not have
as much of a table read like component
as you do so there's a level of jealousy
that I have well that's it's just
different right because your your your
form is different from this form it is
your form is a conversational form the
form we're playing with is it's more
like I mean on the page it looks like a
film script it's and they're these
different all these different voices and
sound effects since this stuff coming
together that's and there's no there's
no straight conversation and the there's
a part of me that would like to just
take say the two hours I spent with Tim
Galway and just release it because a lot
of it was really interesting but but he
had a Viet of you know he had a narrow
role to play in that particular story
suffice to say if you'd need if you need
an outlet for these longer form
interviews with people like Galway there
there may be an avenue you know well
it's interesting it's interesting to
know because we've got I mean out to
years of this stuff and I've interviewed
at length some they've been some really
interesting interviews that just got you
know I used this little snippets from
that and there's some interviews where
the we didn't use any of it and where I
thought the interview was fabulous but
it just didn't you know it didn't serve
the fence yeah yeah it's I I maybe
option see if need are no or option B
solace we'll figure that out yes we
could bookmark that okay i I have a just
a head full of additional questions for
you and okay I can let you get back to
your day the question if exercise the it
seems like you'd exercised regularly I
would love to just hear you speak to
how you exercise when you exercise if it
is in fact an important element of your
days or weeks my wife and children make
fun of how much I exercise and it is one
of those addictions I've encouraged in
myself it just because it seems to me
it's a magic pill right it's the closest
thing there is to a magic pill and it
makes me it not only makes me feel just
better all the time it makes me think
better so an exercise for me is I'm
usually kind of working while I'm
exercising all kinds of ideas are
popping in my head and so it's useful so
what I do I mean pandemic exercise is a
little different from non pandemic
exercise but in a non pandemic world I
try to do something different every day
like never do the same two things
back-to-back and the portfolio of
activities is long bike rides like
really long bike rides and or peloton
rides I have a peloton in my house long
hikes I used to run but I stopped
running four or five years ago because
just my joints didn't like it swimming I
have I suck at it like I've when I jump
in the pool I drown I just I really I
just have a my body just goes to the
bottom of the pool and I've never been
I've always been able to kind of keep
myself afloat but it's never been
something I'm good at but I have this
incredibly gifted female swimming coach
who screams at me for an hour as I go
back and forth in the pool and she's
actually and she keeps pushing me to do
crazy things like we swam Alcatraz and
that's which I should never somebody who
is not yes I'm not a swimmer I'm really
not a swimmer and the so so I do that I
play tennis I used to play a lot of
basketball that's something also I gave
up just because it's it you heard
basketball games we're starting to look
like scenes from a war where you know
that every day you went out you knew
someone was going there's gonna be a
casualty it was just a question who in
the unit was gonna go down and it was
like a Pam string or an Eeyore and I
just thought if you know I just I just
can't do this anymore
so the injury the cost
the injury got too high tennis is the
last competitive sport I think I replay
tonight but basketball I do go
one-on-one with my 13 year old son which
is great
I can play half-court so I do all those
things and I always try to do I do I'll
do at least 45 minutes a kind of intense
cardio a day but usually more than
usually substantially more than that and
and others you know some weight this
weights and stuff like that Ivan and I
have a trainer who I meet with two or
three times a week who makes me move my
body in ways that I don't normally move
my body oh and the last thing is once a
week non pandemic I'll do a Bikram yoga
class again just to kind of stay
flexible so yes I do a lot of stuff and
I wished you know I had a 25 year old
body and I could still do the stuff I
really used to do I mean I used to love
long runs and I used to love basketball
that was just like the best but I can't
do it anymore it seems like you're still
putting in do mileage mm and then oh
yeah it's the best way possible and I
feel I feel I don't know about you but I
feel if I go a day without working out
in some way I feel rotten I mean I just
feel like crap and so it this is my body
is forcing me to do it and I'm glad that
my body's forcing me to do it but it's
uh it does it's like I assume that's the
way you're supposed to live that you're
supposed to be especially since there's
a lot of rest my life is sedentary I
mean I'm at a desk it's funny how when
you bump up against people who don't do
it how weird they think it is but but
it's but for me it's just like therapy
and I sort out all kinds of literary
problems if I have a problem with
anything I'm writing if I just go for a
bike ride or or go walk up a mountain
the problem is resolved by the end of it
it just resolves itself and so it's it's
like central to my existence and it's
also I would say I have this in common
with almost I'd say all my close friends
all my close friends are people who can
hop on a bike and go 40 or 50 miles
and and just like doing it or go for you
know 20 mile hikes there and they all do
it so I guess it does sit in the middle
of my life and it's sort of replaced you
know sports was the middle of my life
till I was 19 years old you know growing
up I was just I was identified as an
athlete and I played lots of sports and
and those eventually you got you know
you're no longer able to play but this
is sort of the next best thing so just
just a few more questions and if these
lead us to dead ends then I'll take full
responsibility all right
the first is what books outside of your
own have you gifted the most to other
people are there any books that you have
given more than once as oh yes I've got
I've got in fact it's funny because I've
just sent a couple of friends a pair of
novels and one of the novels I've sent
to a dozen people and it's a rant it
will seem like a random choice to you
but it's like one of these books that
it's just a miracle of a book it's
called the longships and it's by a
Scandinavian historian it's a novel by
Scandinavian historian who only wrote
one novel I think his name is Franz
Bengston and it's it is a he was a
Viking historian and he packed
everything he knew about the Vikings
into this wonderful comic novel and at
the end of it you feel like you were a
Viking for you know 400 pages and it was
it's just a piece of history that he
just brings to life in this story and I
hand that out all the time partly
because it is just a incredible
pleasurable reading experience and
partly just to illustrate a point then
you never know where great books are
gonna come from it's not like it you
know there there are lots of examples of
people even very late in life like a
book just pops out of him and it was
there one book the other book that my
read my pandemic reading gift I've been
given to people because it's a perfect
pandemic novel is a mortal's is a
gentleman in Moscow and it's about a
Russian aristocrat who during the
revolution
he's the kind of guy who was supposed to
be shot but because of certain qualities
he isn't shot and instead they lock him
up in the Metropole Hotel in Moscow and
he doesn't leave for his for the next 50
years and so you're stuck inside this
place and it's sort of Eloise for
grown-ups
a and B and just beautifully done but it
makes you I mean in this moment it makes
you see the possibilities of
resourcefulness in a confined space but
I yeah I they're a bunch of books that I
give to people but those are the two
that I've just recently in the last week
sent to people do any I'm gonna check
out the longships was it yep the do any
non-fiction books come to mind or do you
gift mostly fiction mostly fiction
mostly fiction they're memoir their
memoirs that I've given more than once
the people Clive James is unreliable
memoirs Gerald Darrell's my family and
other animals essentially comic memoirs
I mean we're just really funny books the
they're they're books that you know
they're books that I just found moving
in all kinds of ways that our odds that
I'll go grab and send to people there's
a book that I you know I've never seen
anybody talk about it or write about it
but when I read it I thought I mean it
in a funny way it was helpful for liars
poker it was a book called the innocent
anthropologist do you know this book I
don't all right Nigel barley is the
author and Nigel barley was a graduate
student doing his PhD in anthropology at
Cambridge and he's got the knotty
problem of what he's gonna write his
thesis about and he goes in to meet with
his adviser and what normally people
were doing and this would have been in
kind of the mid 70s where they were
finding you know on tribes that had not
been described you know people in remote
parts of the world who had not been
visited by an anthropologist and you go
do your anthropological PhD about this
tribe but the adviser says there none
left
like this visit there's nobody left to
write about you keep that old trick of
finding some
and going in and doing their
anthropology it's not gonna work
but then the adviser says I take that
back there's one but they're so boring
nobody wants to write about them and
it's a tribe called the dawai Oh people
in northern Cameroon and he goes and
lives with the do io people he's told
the only things they do there's some
mating ritual and there's also they
drink beer all the time and other than
that they don't do anything and that
that's why he should not write us thesis
but instead II writes this wonderful
travel book memoir anthropological study
of these incredibly interesting people
in northern Cameroon who have disguised
how interesting they are by seeming only
to drink beer and mate and and they sort
of shielded themselves from
anthropological inquiry and this book it
was just you know books very responsive
to people who can make me laugh on the
page and that was one of the funniest
books I've ever read nice every now and
then and when I can find it I give that
away because again it's sort of like a
surprising book you have mentioned a
number of quotes from say Amos and
others that are very sticky in the
course of this conversation if you could
put a message quote question anything at
all on a billboard metaphorically
speaking that would reach billions of
people does anything come to mind
non-commercial that you might put on a
billboard saying a mantra something you
remind yourself of anything at all all
right but so let me just it's going to
be it's gonna sound trite whatever I say
and let me just let me just say let me
just say that I live in the world's
capital of bumper stickers at Berkeley
California hood there there are more
bumper stickers per automobile than
anywhere else in the world it's been
scientifically proven and that you can
walk down the street and people and it's
mostly political stuff but it's just
like people getting their point across
in bumper stickers and I have never had
a bumper sticker on my car because it is
not one thing I've ever wanted to say
over and over forever I just I'm not a
bumper sticker or quote guy however
you say I got to put it up on a
billboard I would take the mantra of my
high school baseball coach one of the
greatest men I've ever known who is
actually the subject of one of the
podcast episodes and he would just say
it routinely and he just kind of became
part of you he would say don't be good
be great and he said t as he handed you
the ball to go out to pitch a game he'd
say he'd say to you when you were
working out and you just having that
mine it's the kind of thing I try to
keep in mind when I'm working on
something good is not okay it's like if
you're gonna do it be great like push
yourself and and it's hard and you know
don't just stop when it's good enough so
that that's what I would stick on a
billboard it's a sort of on the it's one
of those things that's in the billboard
of my mind don't be good be great I love
it that's Billie Fitzgerald Billy
Fitzgerald episode two I have loved my
sneak peek of this new season of against
the rules I encourage everybody to check
it out as you've done a wonderful job
the whole team has done a great job on
it it's available on Apple podcasts
Spotify stitcher wherever you might find
your podcasts you can find more
information at ATR podcast.com that's as
in against the rules a TR podcast.com
Michael are there any other websites or
any other resources social media handles
anything that you would like to mention
if people want to learn more about what
you're up to or wave hello through the
ether of the Internet I wish I could say
yes but I don't do social media so the
answer is no I feel so inadequate I know
I have no way to be found
that's so yes I think room I work look
to your boot soles that that's that's
the wit line right that I'm just that
I'm just isn't you know this there's not
much of me on the Internet
what a what a what a gift
to you to yourself and your family I
think it's it's a rarity I remember when
I asked Laird Hamilton this big wave
surfer once I said where can people find
you and he said the Pacific Ocean so
you're in your verified cup verified
company yeah and so you got people
typing in www Pacific Ocean calm looking
for Laird Hamilton
where is he said who's gonna be here Oh
Michael this has been such such a
pleasure and I really appreciate you
carving at the time I've really enjoyed
our conversation so if I'd Kim thanks
for thanks for having me of course and
to everybody listening everything we
discussed including of course against
the rules
ATR podcast.com all of the books
everything can be found in the show
notes as per usual at Tim de Blanc for
slash podcast and until next time thanks
for tuning it hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun for
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by you
can that's UCAN I was introduced to you
can and it's unique carbohydrates super
starch by my good friend and listen her
favorite doctor Peter
attea while you know that is and she
said there is really no carb in the
world quite like it and just as context
Peter has spent two to three years at a
time in ketosis that is effectively with
a diet absent of carbohydrates but Peter
is written about how he stayed in
ketosis while using you can regularly
and how there is almost no insulin
response is very odd it's very unusual
and there's a cool story behind it which
I'll tell you about as Peter has written
it does not behave like a carbohydrate
with respect to insulin secretion and
ketone suppression so I have since
included it in my routine using you cans
powders to power my workouts and the
bars also as great snacks specifically
the chocolate anytime energy bar at just
180 calories has been a lifesaver it
helps me to stay sharp even if I start
to fade at the end of the day and I
suppose that isn't surprising when you
consider that super starch has been
shown in studies to improve accuracy at
the end of soccer game and improve
cognition when you are exhausted the
company back story is really interesting
it was founded with a mission to help
children with a rare metabolic disorder
that prevents the body from producing
glucose on its own you cans discovery of
a patented carbohydrate that as
mentioned is called super starch now
help those children sustain glucose
levels to keep them alive now in the
world of performance you can is
regularly purchased by more than 400 pro
and college teams that have won every
imaginable championship keeping their
athletes energy steady in the weight
room on the field and elsewhere
extensive scientific research and
clinical trials have shown the super
starch provides a sustained release of
energy to the body without spiking blood
sugar you can is the ideal way to source
energy from carbohydrate without the
negatives associated with fast carbs
especially sugar so you can avoid
fatigue hunger cravings loss focus
that with this technology whether an
athlete working on your fitness or you
need efficient calories to get you
through your day you can is an elegant
energy solution so check it out this
stuff is very very cool and you guys my
listeners can save 25% on your first you
can order by going to you can code
that's you see am dot the CEO and using
promo code Tim that's you can go and
promo code Tim you also get free
shipping if you are in the u.s. so check
it out go to you can Co use promo Tim
for 25% off and free shipping that is us
only on your first order and that when
in doubt just try the chocolate any time
energy bar is simply fantastic you can
Co from a code Tim this episode is
brought to you by Reid wise Reid wise is
one of the cooler things I've found in
the last year or two sent to me by one
of my best friends it is an app that
helps you remember significantly more of
what you read in fact on average their
users report removing 84 percent more of
what they've read and highlighted and it
can take a few different forms you can
sign up for the service that's read wise
dot io forward slash Tim and get daily
email which I do so I've got in front of
me one example with highlights from my
randomness sapiens priceless a bunch of
other books and it has much of advanced
features on top of them but we've all
had the experience of reading a book or
article looking back a couple of weeks
later to realize that you don't remember
anything from it or next to nothing
read wise solves this problem by
integrating on Kindle Pocket iBooks
instagiffer and more to send you a daily
digest of all your highlights so it
helps you to build a fun daily habit
I love getting these emails which I
can't believe it syncs I hate you know
but I love getting these so you get a
daily email and simplest form and you
can review and actually use the hundreds
or perhaps thousands of highlights that
are just sitting in your reading devices
collecting cyberdust and this simple
habit of reviewing your highlights daily
can dramatically improve how much
information you
with your spaced repetition and actually
use and quite frankly it's just fun it's
really fun to see what you've
highlighted over the years and forgot
about so it's really good I mean these
are things that ostensibly you want it
to remember read wise also provides the
tools for organizing your books articles
and highlights so tagging searching
adding notes reading flashcards all that
kind of stuff you can even tell read
wise to automatically export your
highlights to Evernote this is a big
deal for me I've had to do this manually
in the past read wise makes it painless
and super super simple and it just takes
seconds to sign up I was astonished by
this I thought the importing from the
Kindle would take a little long time it
takes no time at all and believe it or
not you can also use read wise with
paper books that is if you have a paper
bag or something you can automatically
get the top popular highlights for your
books simply by adding their titles and
you can also create your own highlights
with the apps camera highlighting
feature this stuff is super cool so
there's no reason not to try this out I
think it's incredibly incredibly useful
and incredibly cool very fun go to read
wise dot io forward slash Tim it's read
wise not I go forward slash ten for two
month free trial offered exclusively to
Tim Ferriss to listeners again that's
read wise dot IO fold slash Tim for two
month free trial realize do forward
slash ten check it out
[Applause]